thank you so great to be back yes we
were off for the month of July and I
have been welcomed backed by two
Republican debates thank you Jesus
- did you see both Republican to
describe this experience have you ever
taken ecstasy it was the opposite of
that
okay and they should have spaced I think
the two Republican debates out more cos
my brain was still trying to recover
from the tsunami of stupid from the
first one when I was hit by another wave
I mean for a minute I thought I was
watching a Comedy Central Roast of the
US Constitution and oh yes the first one
at the baby table oh my gosh the first
one had Rick Perry Carly Fiorina Bobby
Jindal Wow you throw in carrot top it
was a great episode of politically
incorrect and then there was a little
break between debates during which there
was one awkward moment when Trump asked
Rubio to bring his car around I was a
gap
I will admit and and then the main event
and as always at Republican debates they
first brought out Reagan's skull so they
could all touch it for walk
and here's what I think is the big story
from this divin notice if they said this
debate was on fox news they did the
polling to pick the people and I am
quite sure Roger Ailes who runs that and
maybe America
he doesn't like Trump the word came down
get Trump killed this [ __ ] Rosemary's
Baby monster in its black crib I swear
that's exactly what he said so they let
Trump speak three times more than
anybody else and he did he revealed
himself to be nasty Boris sexist
ignorant smug what they forgot is that's
what the Republicans loved about him
that's why his numbers are double of the
guy in second place who's Jeb Bush but
Jeb says he doesn't mind getting the
second most votes he says that's how his
brother got elected president
to understand today's Republican Party
and I know you want to you have to
understand that despite the fact that
they had on the stage five governors
three senators a brain surgeon first and
foremost they wanted to get the opinion
of Donald Trump a ham colored cartoon
character from I love the 80s I mean
once you what you accept that the rest
of the night makes perfect sense mr.
Trump your thoughts on war and peace and
then we will go to morgana the kissing
bandit on deficit reduction dr. Ruth on
entitlement spending and mr. T what
about abortion in the case of rape and
incest beetlejuice you have 30 seconds
for rebuttal
but you know who Republicans are
actually mad at today the moderators
they thought they were to tie got to
give him credit they were chef
especially megyn kelly went right at
them Wow
ya know she can be good she wasn't
mincing words ben Carson you don't know
dick about anything what are you doing
here Trump you're a huge sexist [ __ ]
Marco Rubio are you old enough to buy
beer Scott Walker what's wrong with your
face
it look like the kid who's carrying a
dead bird in his pocket but you know
what after all the fireworks and the
name-calling and you hugged him and you
hugged him it was that the answers were
the same as ever Muslims are coming to
kill us
Mecca zinger Mexicans are coming to
rapist and if you get impregnated by one
you have to bring it to term you know
that's all they have to sell fear hope
and change meat pee and pants I mean the
entire slated them up there seemed
completely unaware of the fact that
women can now vote
right megyn kelly asked Trump right off
the bat about Trump calling women fat
pigs dogs and slobs Trump's answer I
don't have time for political
correctness he's like one of those
construction workers in the 70s like a
nice tits Oh what I can't compliment a
lady anymore it's crazy they all want to
get rid of Planned Parenthood that's
obvious I mean they talk about vaginas
like the Northern Lights
you know I I've never seen it but my
friend has I hear it's breathtaking
you